what's going on reject nation we're
gonna continue the boys today
season two episode two subscribe click
that notification bell to get notified
whenever we got one of these boys
reactions up here on the channel this is
a
friendly reminder youtube only allows
for 10 minutes worth of footage
generally speaking to be included of the
show so this qualifies as reaction
highlights full length reaction watch
along as we sync up with the time code
will be available at our patreon page
speaking of which we really appreciate
you guys
showing your support becoming a patron
jack today over there we do
many tv show reactions all at the same
tier with reaction highlights and watch
alongs included and those shows are what
are they craig
supernatural doctor who jojo's bizarre
adventures the promised neverland attack
on titan death note my hero academia
curtis hanahan
one punch man puma alchemist violet
evergarden demon slayer and there's
plenty of shows that we only do watch
alongs for them we also got a weekly q a
podcast really appreciate you guys
showing your support becoming a petronja
today
let's get into this shall we
oh crap can't go into this reaction
without mentioning eric over at nerd
chronic who is an amazing editor edits
for a movie trivia showdown a whole
bunch of reactors might have seen before
he has a podcast wherever podcasts are
found thank you so much for being as
awesome as you are please give him a
follow
because he is incredible amazing in bed
and a generous guy
hi welcome to endless pasta we get tony
cicerone
endless pasta
this looks like the black angus in
perfect
he just starts filling in the drawings
doing amazing
i can do this where are you going going
to make a concert
what is their actual name
you'll love it no i won't i'll did air
right
i hope he has a cameos no she was
already dead when i blew her up
[Laughter]
totally we're just gonna pretend like
this is normal well who else
oh man there's a civil war
pretty cool huh like do you have any
other outfits
that's okay uh loser you'll uh you'll
get the next one you're not my son
[Laughter]
you're my son
told you what you're capable of when i
showed up at the end of season one you
had laser eyes
we had a deal a deal that is alive and
well
and running around as free as a goddamn
bird oh he saved uh
what's his face for him it's oppressive
energy
that's it they're gonna do just gotta
realign things
ooh dmt what is it true ayahuasca last
time i did shrooms
was that a goo dolls goo goo
wait are you not gonna drink any oh
what when
rayfish are suing warner brothers
you're only here because you're
desperate [ __ ] and you want something
all right [ __ ] it crazy space space wait
wait wait
just hit me out here's a fresco
hey huh in here
open up his gills are talking to him
bro
[Laughter]
love yourself remember melissa dabrowski
the kindergarten teacher you finger bang
backstage at the vh1 educator award
that's patented
turns out my appendix was about to burst
well
there are easier ways to get my
attention you could die from something
like this
but it didn't so i guess you don't need
to save me so glad she put on makeup
while laying in the hospital
the doctor yeah man all those nurses are
strangers that nurse was like oh [ __ ]
woman's in here
the doctor applied that can't show her
bare face
stormfront congrats on the seven are you
as excited to be here as i am
i don't know i don't think so
[Laughter]
i don't think girls do anything better i
think chicks and dicks are in it
together
that rhymes it's good marketing oh
that's me
this is a mislead supposed to make us
like her nah she's bad she's got to be
evil
hot won't let me have pockets in this
on my ass you can practically see up
starlight's uterus
let's talk about getting some pockets
america really is lucky to have such a
brave hero fighting for them
what if i told you we know where he
really is he's right behind you
oh [ __ ] oh no
everyone thinks it was a really good
idea that you called me in for backup
that night
how does everyone feel about you helping
your trainer [ __ ] boyfriend
there you go take a look
a real look oh guys gonna open them up
oh god no oh god oh no okay
look at them in the mirror
you are so
beautiful
[Laughter]
[Music]
they're outside the doorway yeah
what'd you just put in your boot why
don't you tell me
what's in my boot uh oh
he put it in uh stormfront's purse
he did she did oh shall we
yeah you're right verified homelander is
quite upset that this information was
concealed from him
corbett has made a decision not to
antagonize him further
you need to make him leave just keep him
calm our best guess
you'll get bored and move on
[Laughter]
that's a terrible guess homelander and i
went to this oscar party for 12 years a
slave
there's this producer he swapped place
cards so he could sit next to me
two days later there's a fire in his
office they found his head in one room
[Music]
and his torso in another homeland is
jealous
homelander oh no not everyone should be
going against the guy you think
homelander did that
a lot of things yes and i've watched him
do
so she's definitely a goner huh yeah
this season sometimes
you and me are gods
okay son we can do
anything we want don't tell that to a
child
that no one can stop us watch breitbart
hey that's life she should probably go
to bed now you know
i don't want traverse dad oh man he's
kind of a creep
kind
excuse me you need to get the [ __ ] out
of my house
oh no he would kill her
i'm not gonna get bored and move on oh
she's not going anywhere so feel free to
tell dr park to go [ __ ] himself
i want him to take the ayahuasca tea now
[Applause]
that's why
oh she gonna [ __ ] some [ __ ] up
never brother that's right she's gonna
reunite he's gonna reunited
yeah she's gonna hug some [ __ ] up
what's he just doing here
maybe he's the soup terrorist oh
no way to go huey
oh he's got a flash because wowie
damn
[Music]
oh no who's the greatest superhero of
all time
homelander no pippy longstar
pet monkey could lift a horse with one
hand you you haven't read pippy long
stalking
killed dozens of terrorists i have no
idea who baby walks in
i read that book tomorrow one client
this summer
[ __ ] this world for confusing nice with
good
be a [ __ ] if you want pippi
longstocking would bite a d
that's for damn sure
hmm bet we'll see that before the
season's out
becca's alive what she had a little boy
with her spitting image of homeland
before he just wanted i gotta find her
and i gotta get her to [ __ ] out of there
and i need your help to do it oh butcher
getting vulnerable
and but rice you should tell me the [ __ ]
off but still
i'm asking come on guys what would the
spice girls do
break up
okay look you got me i'm having a heavy
flow day it's
oh god dumb [ __ ] you're not gonna do
[ __ ]
why is that because you killed your
[ __ ] girlfriend
all those needles jammed into her arm at
the same
time i mean one of them actually
shattered the bone
did you know that you know say if sports
illustrated found out
if you do that i'm gonna take you down
right with me
i don't give a [ __ ]
give me back my compound feet
now
oh [ __ ] the boys are gonna get her wow
whoa
wow jeez i mean i've had fights with my
brother but um
rip his head off cheers love at least
someone's got some sense around here
[Music]
you had it coming you come between me
mamasas again
i'll [ __ ] kill you
let's talk about it all right guys well
you can still feel there's a percolating
tension happening here there's something
around the
corner something exciting is to come but
right now we're still in setup terrain
right you start off this episode
with getting a little bit uh acquainted
with what's going on with butcher you
see him at the
end of season one and that was it for
him he was just there apparently
and then he got transported back to that
restaurant i actually liked that scene
where he got vulnerable with the game
it's different than
what butcher was like in season one he
was doing a little bit of his con
artist game or not really conor's but
holding out on some truths in order to
get to his goal but he had to become a
little bit more vulnerable in that
sequence not that i want him to go all
super sensitive this season around
but now that he knows his wife is alive
and there's a chance of actually
having her back in his life it makes
sense for his character to have
a bit more of a sensitive angle to him
uh when the when the moment really calls
for it can't wait for him to be ryan's
stepdad
yeah right now co-parenting yeah yeah
yeah you know what there should be a way
of custody battle you know yeah
that's the true drama three season three
yeah
chance and apples will be their lawyer
yeah i really appreciated that too and
it's only one
scene but yeah to get because you know
butcher is such a badass carl urban
plays him so well
it would be really easy for him to fall
into that like uh stereotypical badass
mold and i thought that that moment was
a nice moment of vulnerability that read
really straight and that i just
yeah bought and felt you know even
though it's just one little interlude of
the episode so i watch
a lot of things with olivia and i'm
always the one who's getting grossed out
and she's usually fine this was a rare
moment where i was like oh
she's actually grossed out the gills the
girls
take it away olivia yeah they were gross
do you feel sympathy for him yet
absolutely not why would i
guess what he deserves it's that's
what's weird to me about the perspective
of the show
sometimes though is because it sometimes
seems to take this like sympathetic
angle with him at least in the way the
show's capturing it do you think i'm
sitting here going i'm so glad this
rapist is finally finding his inner joy
yeah exactly he's not a good guy this
show will take this sympathetic approach
with him but they'll also you know still
take a side step even with the gills
talking to him they were saying like the
reason
the way you feel about yourself is the
reason why you do what you do
so the show will still at least be aware
like he's not a good
person though he still does these
terrible things hey man maybe somebody
out there who has done what the deep has
done will have their trauma unlocked by
this little plotline
yeah that's what this should be this
show is trying to connect
this is the demographic that boys is
aiming for right now yeah
we really want people to sympathize with
rapists
i do find that yeah it is it is kind of
an odd angle and i guess i i appreciated
it for just the the sheer blend
of how surreal and goofy but also yeah
kind of psychologically on point yeah
and so yeah it creates this weird
fascination for a character yeah who
like as a person i don't like
i think it's meant to be goofy honestly
yeah because it's not meant to be like
sympathizing i think it's meant to be
look at this is kind of goofy because
he's sitting in there saying
you are so beautiful like that's goofy
yeah exactly so
i guess sympathetic would be the uh not
the crowd but a pitiful look at him yeah
yeah he's pathetic like the only form of
sympathy because he's always the
punchline
yeah that's true even in that very
moment he is but chase crawford
you got to give him like some respect
for the for the kind of performance that
he puts on as much as this show has this
pitiful
look at him he does a great job at
living that character you know
and i've always just known him as a
pretty boy until this show where i'm
like this guy's got some actual acting
chops
and i only assist him as a pretty boy
because i never actually saw his actual
that's work on me it's not from any of
the previous work
girl so okay that's i think that's why i
just thought that even i never saw
gossip problem like i just a pretty boy
you know so this stormfront character
who i who i'm really liking a lot
with the show doing its thing with
talking with commentary with media with
stormfront she's getting all
fed up and being like the outspoken one
and vaught and talking against like the
way
bots pr codes tend to be going against
the the grain of what often gets
kind of like a breed larsen person in
trouble
when you just call out the [ __ ] in
these media interviews
i love the way they uh captured that
there
and i actually like the complexity it's
drawing between the dynamics
of the relationship with her and
starlight we know starlight is really on
more of the side of stormfront here that
she is going through with the act
because she's working undercover in a
lot of ways but you can see why
stormfront also views her as a sellout
exactly yeah i mean that's part of the
identity crisis that she's in
stormfront i don't trust her right
there's got to be something
because i think the show is gearing you
up for this thing of oh maybe starlight
can find a friend a confidante within
stormfront but no she seems way too like
libertarian
yeah yeah there's something happening
here where the show's trying to
set you up for oh maybe she could become
a goodie but no she's not there's
something up with her
because there's something about the way
she she puts out her vibe and like yeah
she's saying the right things and the
things that you want to say but there's
something about the way she
says then suggests like a darker
attitude underneath
yeah i just think it portrays that she's
kind of putting on a front i feel like
because
she just a storm in the front
what's this is her name in the show
[Laughter]
she just joined the seven she's not
trying to get to know them at all she's
not trying to
be included so i feel like there's hints
there that there's
something deeper into why she's there
deep
one funny enough
oh black she saw this
oh man i sort of suspect her of doing
what she accused starlight of doing i
feel like
she's probably collecting info for some
because
she was hired directly by john carlo
esposito
so there's something up with her right
she's different than all of them and
nobody
seems to care that she like in the last
episode she came in like all this bot
stuff is [ __ ]
yeah she's getting away with all of it
yeah but maybe
maybe that's all a bigger part of the
comp beyond just the character like ooh
so pulling out the rug maybe that's
bigger part of the commentary
i think it has to do with the compound b
somehow like maybe
yeah maybe i'm reading too much into the
show it's just with the compound
maybe it could be about compound v but
also about something deeper
yeah perhaps speaking of the compound v
uh a train coming back into the picture
so very fast yeah he
really hasn't told anyone like the truth
you think by now he would have said
something especially upon waking up
i feel like he would have said something
to someone what incentive would he have
to not have said something
i don't know maybe it's a really good
question yeah maybe we'll find out why
he didn't say does he need her for
anything maybe he agrees with what she's
doing
finally because of all the [ __ ] he went
through last season yeah or maybe
there's yeah some like moral part inside
where he's like oh they did save me
yeah i was gonna say maybe he feels
obligated yeah
he definitely feels bad deep down about
popclaw yeah there seems to be something
a little bit different about his
character
yeah because in the last season of
course he's like always on edge he's
really like a drug addict poor people
say maybe he's not high on drugs yeah
exactly it was a drug out of portrayal
but then this time around it seems like
he's had some type of
epiphanies but he's also still an
[ __ ] like i'm not exactly sure what
they're doing with this character a
homeland or wanting to be a daddy
oh yeah homelander wanna be a daddy that
was
interesting i wish he was my dad what is
with his what is with milk
and homelander oh man because he was
like again yeah he can't get that titty
man you got to go to the next best place
he's just uh he's got that infant fetish
i don't know infant fetish well yeah
he's got that whole thing where he loves
like you know mother figure
i thought he loves little boys i was
like no he's got that fetish where he
likes to be the baby
yeah yeah i think you're right it's more
of that
well if people like homeland or the
character maybe
we should buy some breast milk yeah
yeah we should order some i just want to
be more like homelander
without any of like the perverted stuff
except for the baby
milk you know what let's move on for
this subject
you guys think becca's gonna die i think
because i think she's gonna die i think
we're gonna get to know her we're gonna
feel comfortable
be like ah we're gonna get that hope in
somewhere
yeah i think homelanders go like what's
what's the stop homelander from killing
her
i mean if anything she's setting herself
up to be an obstacle in the way
of him feeling like he can truly connect
to
uh his son right it's very interesting
to see her stand up to homelander
because i'm like why
you know what he's capable of how why do
you feel confident enough to do that so
i wonder if she knows something else
well i think there's going to be more
complexities coming in because
she obviously loves her son despite who
the biological
it's clear she made an arrangement with
yeah yeah
one and it seems clear too that the sun
actually has a connection and
relationship
to her which was about the one thing
that made me think okay maybe homelander
is sort of aware of that because it's
clear
he knows he's not connecting even though
he's trying and then that scene that he
had with her
when she was trying to kick him out he
was clearly imposing a lot of blame
on her for why ryan doesn't connect
with him so much and talking about you
know the the possibilities of
you know going to burger king and all
that i remember zach who said i tried
quoting you
left my brain right last episode's gonna
take place in a burger king at a
baseball game
playing catch with super dad i really
like that scene that he had with
ryan what do you think since there's
someone who works with kids what do you
think about this kid actor does he seem
like a real kid
yeah like a dialogue and all that i
think it's real and i think like
his standoff is cooler to this new guy
who's suddenly like hey
i'm your dad and kind of imposing
himself on him i feel like it's all
very realistic yeah kids respond that
way to me all the time
you got to stop trying to be everyone's
father for you guys
every kid you see you're like on the
internet i'm a public figure i gotta
i owe it to them every time i meet a
little kid who i'm like i'm your father
now
your mentor talk to your dad i'm your
father
speaking of uh father's son's familial
relations uh we got kimiko's brother too
which was a good twist on
you know connecting the uh new super
terrorist bit
that was a pleasant surprise i
completely got where he was coming from
yeah we'd look at the real world of
america
it's not exactly great these days but at
the world of the boys
america it's pretty bad it's even worse
so i totally get where the brother is um
is coming from here
yeah but in the world of this he's he
would definitely still be viewed as like
the terrorists i didn't know if they
were going to go down this
approach of oh they're going after the
super terrorists and you find out oh
he's not really a terrorist
who somehow i guess the angle is he's
not really a bad guy
it's clear that our own conception is
sort of motivating what he's up to but
at the same time this is a not gonna fly
with you know the regular america but b
this is definitely not gonna jive with
butcher and their plan
yeah so he's still technically a
terrorist even though he's not a bad
guy one of those things even though like
and you
can count on that playing in i'm sure
some kind of yeah exploration of that
conflict but i just really loved their
scenes together like i really believe
their relationship i love the just body
language things they would do with each
other and the difficulty of the actual
debate of like yeah america's doing some
messed up stuff and she's
you can tell how much she's pleading
with him but there is that you know
wedge between them and i thought that
was really nicely acted speaking of
believable relationships how do you guys
feel about the
elena queen maeve queen mauve
relationship i have a hard time
really because i just feel like she's
going to die eventually
maeve yeah and oh yeah i keep
waiting for maeve to become like a
little cooler
or get more than that like her story
seems to be stuck on this beat
it seems to be like washed up actress
it's kind of like the portrayal they do
with her i've been kind of feeling that
about
certain storyline elements from this
episode the next but i feel like we're
transitioning
out of season one elements and because
of how close this takes place to season
one
it makes sense why there's still so many
things that are like i'm reminded of
season one
of this we're re-bri we're bringing this
story back into the fold and then
eventually i think we're gonna reach a
point where we're just completely moving
forward from the stuff from season one
i think it's interesting because i don't
buy the relationship with the elena girl
number one number two we know homeland
is gonna flip out
he made a comment in the first season
about how if i ever found out
that you were with someone you fell in
love with someone else it would break my
heart or something yeah and then she
even told her today
so i'm like it's all just preparing you
that something bad is gonna happen to
this girl we'll see
yeah but i would like to have more of a
deeper look into homelander and queen
maeve mob's relationship yeah me too to
be able to buy this whole storyline
well and as long as they're gonna have
her and her girlfriend be such a
part of her character story i i would
kind of like to see
more between them than just this beat
you know yeah
get to the part where we're really
attaching to them so that whenever
whatever happens
we're heartbroken yeah exactly and the
last thing i'll point out is i actually
appreciated kind of the ninja-esque
approach to when the brother and kimiko
were fighting with each other he had
some
subtle uses of what our expensive action
scenes you know like even like getting
thrown into the wall or being pushed
into the car or her just
with the wire work of her being floated
into the air when she jumps after him
and kind of how there was like no music
and it was just this tension there
on foot chase and it felt quiet uh i
really liked that a lot i thought in
terms of like an action scene for
usually a show that's
pretty bombastic with its action
sequences like at the store on that i
mean even though yeah that is just all
practical like i
i really felt that yeah they captured
that really well too great stuff man
great stuff all around it's building
yeah everything's still building i get
why they released the first three
episodes at once
because i feel like to really get a lot
locked in latched in
you got to watch the first three
episodes yeah you know we still gotta
get like extra acquainted with like
frenchie right now and all
you gotta finish act one of the seasons
yeah and get into the part where we're
like oh damn i gotta come back next week
yeah yeah because this is and i i
appreciate the kind of gradual build
they've been doing but yeah i feel like
episode three maybe it'll lead to a bang
i was gonna say maybe i feel like next
episode's gonna be kind of crazy so
we'll see let's see a whale in that
image oh get ready it's going to be good
that was going to die
oh no dead animals
all right guys subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell
last but not least
baby i gotta tell you tell me about it i
took a screenshot of something that
naraj
sent me because i mentioned that we keep
passing these indian restaurants
and we never know what to get because we
both don't eat meat oh i found it
and so he told me hey greg indian
vegetarian since you mentioned olivia's
vegetarian dishes to try and then he
lists a whole bunch of delicious dishes
that we could try
narage now because of you are you gonna
buy us indian food
you can now buy us indian food
personally have it sent to us
i will give you my address i'm expecting
a delivery here
20 minutes after this video was uploaded
on youtube thank you so much for being
you dude you've been a very generous
guy you've been a very caring sincere
human being for the longest time man
and uh i love the hell out of you one
day when we are in the east coast we
will meet up
hang out it'll be a blasty blast and you
will serve us indian food
that you made not bought vaught bot vod
body rob with a cod lot okay we're done
[Music]
thanks
[Music]
you